so we're gonna look at this guy at the
curious we're going to try to leave a
waffle lot in this this one class
session yeah devoted together because he
is the founder of an entire school of
philosophy just like play dough just
like Aristotle who had the Academy and
the Lyceum
Epicurus started a philosophy school
called the garden and his influence is
carried out through the modern age some
of the people that you might run into in
pop philosophy or you know current
interest stuff but we're talking about
materialistic views on things or you
know how to live in the absence of
religion those sorts of topics are
actually just recycling of epicurean
ideas
Epicurus had a massive influence of
ancient period not so much of a medieval
period because we was seen as being sort
of and you know opposed to faith opposed
to religion we'll see why in a minute
and then in the modern period he enjoyed
a revival and it's been going on for
quite a while when you hear the word
epicurean and you're thinking in
philosophy don't think of like cooks and
food and gourmets because that's not
quite the same thing
as a matter of fact those are the sorts
of pleasures that people attribute it to
the Epicureans
but in some respects false because they
wanted to say these guys are all about
pleasure that's all they care about
they're a bunch of pigs you know just
why wine women and song but for sex
drugs rocket hole these days and just
let it all hang out and do anything you
can that's not what they were putting
from so you read the text you know that
at the curious is not saying do whatever
feels good to you right because a lot of
that will get you more pain and in
trouble lose a little bit of background
stuff big words that describe that the
Karissa's from the solution so he's a
materialist and what do we mean when we
say materialist sometimes we talk about
you know people being into commodities
into being consumers not materialistic
in that sense materialistic and more
fundamental sense do you think so
everything is made of matter so there is
no such thing as consciousness apart
from manner
there's no immortal soul apart from
matter he believes that the gods exist
but the gods are material we're just way
off there somewhere and hardly you know
describe heaven and they don't have
anything to do with human beings because
that's that's why they're actually happy
you know that's why guys they're smart
enough to stay away from awesome heart
affairs but everything was made a matter
for advocates so everything has to be
explainable or reducible to manage
matter for him is made of atoms he
didn't come up with this idea itself he
got from Democritus one of the very few
people he was influenced by and
Democritus was an even more ancient
philosopher a little bit older than
Socrates who said everything was made of
errors and by atoms he didn't mean to be
mean today what he meant was unbreakable
or uncuttable particle particles our
home comes from
ah primitive prefix and it's made which
means to cut so used to be back in the
day before any of us were born our
ancestors believed that Natomas couldn't
be split and then of course with them
make sure the bombs show you can do that
nuclear fission well you know this basic
idea is that you get all these different
atoms and they get put together in
certain combinations and they're all
actually falling constantly we didn't
realize this but we're falling in a void
and every once in a while some of the
adders swerve in interesting ways and
that produces new combinations and
that's where we get the world from
according to that big cares we're not
going to be that interested in that
stuff because we're mostly interested in
getting to his concept of friendship so
you know the atoms inform your
understanding of friendship is that a
helpful concept for you if it is I'm
love to hear that's because you know I
don't when I think of fans on how I
ought to behave or what constitutes a
friend I don't think of any atoms are
made of I love you for your atoms or
hate you for your atoms materialism that
that might have some things that yeah
well we're really interested as
hedonistic what does that word mean
anybody know that we're offhand your
hedonistic
we do use that in our culture - reading
you know better magazines or higher
literature you will run into this term
it's coming from the Greek word for
something we've been talking a lot about
Hado named pleasure so he reduces the
pleasurable you know like the pleasant
friendship when we talked about either
song so a hedonist if you're pissed of
something you're usually an advocate
right key to nests think of the good and
the enclosure and sort of a bad is pain
and there's really nothing beyond this
for a hedonist this puts everything else
into perspective it is letter to men LCS
he tells us that those two important
things he says pleasures the beginning
and end of living happily for we've
recognized this is the first good the
the good that everything else comes from
insofar as it's good being innate within
us and with reference to it we begin
every choice and avoidance what is what
is an ethics of that is about what we
ought to choose what we want to avoid
how we ought to live our life what kind
of lifestyle we let's go down do this we
come as if we judge them all goodbye
passion as a standard since this is the
first good on this account we don't
choose every pleasure we'll come back to
that in a moment a little bit later he
tells you we don't mean the pleasures of
the debauch man or those who lie in such
those which lie in sensual enjoyment to
something who are ignorant entertain our
opinions are also interpret them
perversely the people that are giving us
a bad rap they think that we're just
talking about debauched pleasures purely
sensual pleasure
Epicurus has something different in mind
so we'll look at that but it's important
to keep this in perspective everything
in the last analysis is going to come
down to being good in terms of pleasure
being bad in terms of pain so you know
you might say well what about my love
for my grandparents well you like them
don't you you enjoy them on some level
work we have to enjoy the thought of
being a good grandchild and not being a
jerk like that other guy over there
that's the sputter if you feel guilty
about not visiting your grandparents or
writing them thank-you notes
grandparents in your generation
sometimes still want thank-you notes you
know and people in your generation and
my generation often don't write
thank-you notes and then you know it
causes them pain and you feel guilty
about that they still don't write the
bank you know because that sort of thing
well that's all about pain and pleasure
and then you can reduce everything down
to those those terms now a little bit
more background not about this stuff
Epicurus starts this school and he is
unusual in antiquity among ancient
philosophers and that his ideas don't go
in some way back to Socrates you know
Plato gets his start from Socrates right
who's who's Aristotle's teacher Plato so
Aristotle Oh certainly is tracing back
to Socrates the cynic school that were
not going to study this semester they
trace back to anticipation was a student
of Socrates
some of the other hedonists the Syrians
they traced back to nearest ah--this who
was by now you know the chorus student
of Socrates the Stoics who we are going
to look at because there are very
important philosophical schools they
actually sort of had an offshoot of
they're both cynics
so they trace back to Socrates and they
trace their whole ideas back to Socrates
Epicurus didn't Epicurus is sort of
standing off on his own doing something
quite different he takes some ideas from
Democritus about the atom ISM but he's
even different from the other humanists
so it's kind of interesting to look at
him unfortunately we don't have an awful
lot by this guy
anybody remember offhand how much stuff
we have if you read through the lesson
sections there are three letters which
are fairly long thankfully Leonard
analysis is the shortest of them and
this principle doctrines and then one
text which I mean from supplying some
quotes from which was discovered in the
Vatican Library
it's a 14th century manuscript called
the Vatican sayings this guy is one of
the most prolific authors in antiquity
he wrote reams and reams and reams of
material we only have three letters and
two sets of sayings and then a lot of
things that people have said about
Epicurus in his school but directly by
him we only have these five texts and
they're all short texts so we have to
piece together his his doctrine it's
kind of a puzzle
or doing detective work in many many
respects why don't we have these types
of people you know if you wanted to keep
a text in the ancient world you have to
keep on copying
and so they didn't copy all of his works
the reason why we have those letters is
because to a Geneva artist himself
put them into his book the lives of the
Philosopher's word for work back then
they weren't worried about plagiarism or
things like that
any attributes he says here's a letter
of Epicurus thank God he did that
because otherwise we wouldn't have
anything by the guy if we didn't have to
actually layer taste stuff we wouldn't
have recognized the Vatican sayings as
being my epic eros he'd be totally lost
to it to the antiquity by the way quite
a few other philosophers like for
example antis the knees or snippets
actually are so let's go back to Gooden
man let's think about basic pleasures
that you enjoy we talked about these
quite a bit what is the range let's take
a student's life
make ourselves to call
what can you rather start with pains or
pleasures rather think about Pleasant
things or get the painful things out of
the way painful okay what is it both
pains in your life and not just physical
pains like you know your bones hurt or
you fell down the stairs
psychological pains things that trouble
you things that yeah okay well come back
to that interesting thing about why is
that my attempt unpleasant we'll come
back to that what else yeah
okay finding relationships romantic
relationships we say both friends and
imagine not ruling out the possibilities
could of course coincide say nobody can
be at home to be friends
what else
okay
these are pretty weighty things you guys
are coming up with yeah money unless
they're like a little bit that's a big
issue will be probably enough but right
now money issues there's a wide scope
doesn't and really have a much bigger
problem for your generation of my
generation that was for your
grandparents and my parents baby boomers
who can afford to go to school pretty
cheaply could find jobs pretty easily
it's easy for them to invest you know
this is my generation was the first that
I actually had a declining standard of
living and your generation is continuing
that that's the bad news
so what else well let's not talk about
pleasures what are the things that you
enjoy in your life correct
you find satisfaction and you have fun
seek out your pleasure
yeah all right what else yeah it's
probably different for everyone but
hobbies okay yeah I think people do
hobbies hopefully because it thank them
Pleasant not because well it's Tuesday
and Tuesday it's hobby day so I need to
actually go work out the model trains or
you know take care of the rabbits or
ever be a real drag what else
surely you guys doing pleasures I hope
like this is just a drudgery is the
students okay
let's say sleep and relaxation alright
when you're asleep you probably don't
remember what's going on too much but
you probably do enjoy relaxing laying on
the couch that's why we like couches it
wouldn't be invented if we did enjoy
Lane
or other enjoyments yeah
gotta be like eating yeah so I quit
eating and drinking down you guys like
you can drink
all right we actually look at this just
make sure it's actually yeah okay now we
could break these down further what is
it you actually like it either
what are the pleasures that come with
that what is it that you like about
learning you know having to do
schoolwork and learning can go hand in
hand
why is the activity partly Pleasant and
partly unpleasant yeah here's here's
something to think about if you could
learn in the way that you want to at the
time that you want to and turn on your
own schedule the things that you're
particularly interested in it'd be much
more pleasure right than pain I would
suspect that part of the reason why if
you are not not enjoying all your
classes that you're not enjoying your
classes that they're getting convenient
times you got stuck into classes you
weren't particularly interested in
taking the Registrar put you in there or
your adviser said well you need this for
you look for your core requirements
that's what the thing and then I can
make it drudgery even those classes that
you want to major in there's things that
could make the class really boring right
their teacher just lectures in a
monotone and all the time and uses
PowerPoint slides
incessantly you know I don't know if
you've had any teachers like that
probably will sooner or later that's no
fun what else makes a class we're
learning experience painful unpleasant
you're like that before
so yeah it seems like the spider the
pain like having to use for
which is the pleasurable aspect yeah in
class if the pain descends up in
yeah that's a really good point when you
were in high school did you have yeah
you probably ask your teachers sometimes
why do we have to study this stuff when
are we ever going to use it and good
teachers who are actually knowledgeable
about their subject and have some degree
of passion about you think you usually
like on the spot tougher right
did you ever get the response look this
is just something that you need to learn
for its own sake I know I been legal I
had a class when I was in middle school
it was an anthropology class because I
went to a special middle school and the
whole class class session after class
session consisted in the teacher
standing up at the front and saying now
open your books up to page 36 beginning
of the word and the second paragraph
underlying until you reach anthropologic
cultural anthropology or something like
that the entire class almost every
session was his him telling us what to
underline and the books that he had us
by for class can you imagine that that's
a class would that be just don't defile
a boring butt and I actually got a bad
grapes I didn't underline the right
stuff
maybe one of those cases you're like why
the hell am i underlining this you know
what's the point of underlining first of
all you guys do that too sometimes right
why do you underline things because the
teacher thinks are important but the
teacher things are reported the teacher
can underline it itself or you don't put
it in italics why do you have like
because you'd actually care about that
and you think it's worth underlining
right that's why different people's
textbooks have different things under
line or you write things on the other
side it can even be just like this guy's
this guy doesn't know what the hell he's
talking about
that's you being involved okay that
makes it kind of fun you know I start
drawing my textbooks all the time do it
all and you know I gotten a lot of
trouble for that sort of stuff this is
stupid
this is actually a very bad student in
many respects it's amazing I'm teaching
your guys in the first place
think about relationships I notice
relationships are again in both parts -
right finding relationships that's kind
of kind of a pain sometimes but that can
be kind of fun to Kanton you know dating
is in some respects trying out a
relationship is that why else do you go
on dates if they're dating it's not yet
a sure thing but it's actually going to
work it's a sure thing you need to get
married or you know become nervous or
something like that make some sort of
commitment to each other why is it a
pain to go find relationships this
something I think all of you can relate
whether friends or romantic
relationships why is that not
necessarily painful that's like you know
poke yourself in the eye physical pain
but there there are negative feelings
they come about yeah that's a huge one
we don't want like rejection right and
and it happens in a lot of different
ways even once you're in a relationship
you can feel the rejection from the
other person captcha turns out that they
really didn't like this this thing that
you were into and they just said it
while you were dating so that you'd like
them and you feel rejected a lot of envy
is actually about feeling rejected by
the other person
let happenin on not just romantic
relationships or friend relationships
your friend is spending too much time
with that person over there you feel bad
about that but on the other thing I'm
friends can be a great great thing in
your life you can thing it makes your
life much more pleasurable and more
complete in many ways romantic
relationships are they necessary sooner
or later
for most people's wives what do you
think
do we do we need them or are these a
luxury maybe maybe you guys you know
there's marriage
college students now you should really
just buckle down and pay attention to
your your classes and make sure you get
the internships that you need don't date
anybody
matter of fact don't even flirt with
anybody because that's just gonna leave
the dating and that's going to be a
problem that's going to distract you
from that far off life goal of you know
what's going to happen after graduation
maybe you should leave all that sort of
stuff aside that's not good to you or
your life be less pleasant without let's
just think about just flirting right or
even forget flirting just think about
looking at people that you remind
attractive if you really wanted to
manage your time well wouldn't you be
better off saying am I gonna look at
anybody attractive when I see somebody
attractive come on and the commercials
like do something else I'm gonna think
about philosophy or my business
marketing class or do some flashcards or
something like that that makes sense if
you have you chosen that sort of life
for yourself I hope not because not only
would you be making yourself miserable
but you would be quite a miserable
person to be around
I don't like that in the students know
if you do want to learn some of them's
you probably do have to buckle down you
can't just do anything you like but
friends and and romantic relationships
we see those is a good thing they can
bring a lot of problems as well and the
things that we fear hobbies have
anything over here that's like the no
good hobbies turn into a pain yeah you
know if you what are some people's
hobbies and you're into
working out that's a good hobby yeah
because then it's actually got some
benefits for you what if you work out
and then don't work out for a while then
you first if you like guilty right and
that's you know that's on the negative
side maybe shouldn't work out in the
first place maybe that's not to work out
probably not that's what that's actually
bad line of reasoning I played the banjo
and I play the banjo because I'm lazy
because my dad played the banjo because
that was big you know folk music when he
was in college so he bought a banjo and
later on down the line I inherited that
when he died and I messed around with a
vid in high school but I never actually
like learned an evangelistic you know
like bluegrass or stuff like that
instead I just learned whatever I want
to learn you know Black Sabbath songs or
John Cougar Mellencamp songs or
Motorhead things like that stuff you're
not supposed to play on a banjo but it
actually sounds fairly good on a banjo
and I don't put in the time and work
that I ought to to actually get good at
what I'm doing because I just like
messing around
yeah I figure so I said I like it son
let me let me learn that it might be
anything you know to be goldfrapp to be
pick whatever you like if somebody's
playing a song and I like the way it
sounds
I'll see if I can put it on the banjo I
haven't always done that I used to play
the bass guitar for a long time yeah
you guys quit playing that in graduate
school and I picked up the banjo
became a professor just it has something
to make music with I enjoyed that
my biggest irritants when I play the
banjo and I just cringe when people ask
me about this can you play Zhu Ling
banjos you know a song from deliverance
did it in Ben didn't bend them no I
can't and I don't want to learn that
because I'm uninterested in that sort of
playing I should I was interested in
that but it drives me nuts
so my hobby can end up going over here
on the other side am do you know if I
don't put in the time to practice my
fingers get you know less nimble and
that can produce pain if I get too into
it eventually don't you play guitar or
instruments like that stringed
instruments what happens to your fingers
after after a while you have a very long
session it they get sore yeah I used to
when I played bass I used to play so
much that I actually had to put like
hands on my fingers because we wear away
the flesh on your fingers and your thumb
your thumb as well those are big thick
straps very abrasive so there to be pain
involved as well yeah this is a big one
how many of you had somebody close to
you died during your lifetime almost
everybody in the class and guaranteed
everybody in the class everybody
anywhere anytime is going to have people
close to them dying because the human
mortality rate is a hundred percent and
everybody that you know either will die
before you or you will die before them
or you will die at the same time that's
a very morbid thought and
I don't mean to be a huge downer and
ruin your day but it's worth putting
things in perspective you will have to
deal with death you'll have to deal with
sickness you have to deal with missing
people you'll have to deal with people
exiting your life and all sorts of
different ways loss treatments
abandonment that is something that we
have to deal with money issues huge
problems right how much money does it
take to live comfortably have you
thought about that like an actual dollar
amount when you get out of Marist look
not let's say not right away because
you're gonna have to do an entry-level
job or something like that right away
unfortunately how much would you like to
be earning again five years out in
today's dollars so you don't have to try
to adjust if your head translation you
know multiply by a factor of what one
1.85 know just how much if you were if
you were where you would be five years
from graduation so about ten years from
now how much money would you need to
make a year in order to feel like you're
you're making enough what would you what
would you like to be me don't say a
number like you know of ten million
dollars let's make it very realistic
what would you need yeah seventy-five
thousand to be comfortable right okay
now is there like living in a city
because that wouldn't cover anything
yeah but varies from where you know
standard of living right so living in
suburbs you buy a bigger house than a
good nativity what is it that you want
that money to buy for you that this
might get better way to do it five years
from now what would you like to get
besides money in the bank in case you
maybe have fired or something bad
happens what would you like to have in
your life yeah car any old car ten year
old junker BMW okay good
set the bar high you know not a Porsche
cuz you know your insurance would be
through the roof and you don't really
need of course but BMW is a good
reliable car around here the thing that
people really like is Subarus
car is just beginning right you could
live in your car that's accurately a
nice way to live what's up yeah we're
trying to get a picture what that what
this gonna look like in terms of what
you need for four possessions well well
now that's Epicurious this point you're
jumping ahead a little bit so that's
quite all right you know if you're if
you're content to drive a car that's
older you don't need a super new fancy
cut if you don't need serious radio in
your car you save a little bit of money
each one you know if you can listen to
the mp3 or CD is instead or books on
tape whatever yeah you can lower these
these expectations and Epicurus will do
that but let's say we want to set up
high I mean I would wonder how wouldn't
you want a house and ideally one that's
paid for but you know even one whose
payment you can afford that would be
nice
how how big of a house do you agree to
be okay with like a little one bedroom
bungalow or would you prefer to have you
don't need like that you know 30 bedroom
10 bathroom mansion 10,000 square feet
probably did - do you have a hard time
not a lot of those around I'm big in the
house cute do you want these are things
we're thinking about
do you want to go on vacation how often
you want to go on vacations where do you
want them to be do you want to go to
shows or plays or the movies or other
entertainment things that's something
you put in your budget and when you're
thinking about these things money is a
big issue what are some of your great
fears respect money know some of your
hopes and dreams what are some of your
fears yeah yeah there never seems to be
enough of it right whenever you get it
this is a common experience people get a
new job and they're making more money in
they're like oh right now everything is
going to fall into place I'm finally
making enough to cover everything and
then usually when it's up happening his
expenses will still exceed income
somehow expenses will almost always rise
unless you decide to live simply so that
is something you would have to worry
about losing a job losing a job is
catastrophic for many people as going
through a divorce a lot of people live
you know just two paychecks away from
the collection agencies calling in our
society that's been going on for years
that's you know that that gives you a
lot of anxiety to live that way people
go that's not very fun one of the terms
they haven't put up here that we want to
thank occurs up with both of these is
desire and
here fear is a pain desire is a
pleasures yeah there are Epicurus things
up there but we could call positive
pleasures you know like eating and
drinking you know okay if you're really
super hungry eating and drinking becomes
a matter of satisfying a need yeah but
we don't want to feel that hungry in our
society and a lot of times we we don't
choose the cheapest food or the most
nourishing food we choose stuff that
tastes really good right we choose the
fancy stuff we say I'm not going to that
restaurant I'm going to this one over
here you know I want my hamburger with
this and this and this silence you know
can't just have a regular hamburger it
needs to be mushroom swiss or maybe some
bacon on it or you know they put an
onion on but they didn't put good
pickles will get upset about that circle
thing because they want you know the
fancy food and you know spending time
with your friends that's that's a
natural positive pleasure quite often
you do things together
sleeping and relaxation that's kind of
an interesting one because a lot of the
pleasures that epicurus thinks that we
have are not so much positive pleasures
in their own right there what happens
when we take away pains or worries or a
troubled mind or our fear so when you
like lay down to sleep and you let's say
we get on everything that's perfect
conditions it's just just the right
temperature in the room you know now's a
good time of year because it's like that
bad good sleeping weather it's kind of
humid kind of cool you open the windows
up get under the covers
it's probably sounding pretty good so
early morning there's some positive
pleasures involved but a lot of it is
just your body relaxing not feeling any
pain rejuvenating itself when you're
laying on the couch and you don't have
anything on the to-do list anymore
and you're not worried about anything
that's a nice condition that's enough
that's that's a pleasure but it's not so
much a pleasure where you can point out
something saying here's the cause of my
pleasure I'm drinking some coffee and I
love the taste of this know it's
affecting my taste buds it's causing
pleasure in my mind it's something
positive it's also something you know
taking away a negative two is I'm in the
addict to coffee so if I don't get the
caffeine I get these terrible headaches
but for you know fight if I keep myself
on enough of a dose I don't worry about
that and I can just have that positive
pleasure learning is a positive pleasure
it might also be sort of a primitive
thing you take away your ignorance you
take away your not knowing about
something either some things that you've
learned in your life where after you
learn them you're like I have to worry
about that anymore
now I can actually rest easy some of
these are things like in a learning that
you're not in default insurmountable or
that you can transfer your credit card
balances over here at 0% interest for
another year or that your car just needs
you know a cheap part rather than a
thousand dollar repair or you know you
don't have cancer
think of it there used to be back in the
day here's what kind of a fight story so
nowadays you know if they want to test
you for HIV
they just do this swab thing and they
can felt right on the spot used to be
back in the day that if you were you
know just an ordinary person
two weeks to get your results and I
remember you know having to have a test
at one time and then as soon as you have
one of those tests your mind starts
running through all sorts of
possibilities just stuff that's not even
rational my life be like oh my god this
is this is terrible
then you gotta wait two weeks I was so
nervous by then I didn't actually have a
reason but I was so nervous by the time
that I actually went to get my results I
brought my friend along with me to the
doctor's office there so I was upset and
then afterwards finding out nowyou
you're fine
Wow I felt elated and on top of the
world I can start planning things again
that you know that's learning something
that puts things in perspective
Epicurus what are the sort of things
that he thinks about my life death are
any of you dreading your own death
hopefully not your age if you can orbit
or you know you think you're deeply
about things you might you might realize
that you could die tomorrow you might
wonder whether your life had meaning you
might worry about what's going to happen
to your friends and family you might
think about different ways to die and
how painful they would be you know like
drowning I really don't want to drown I
think about it you know there's
something about like the three things in
the water
idea and you can say we don't think
about this but now that I've actually
put the idea in your head you're all
stuck you know thinking about it at
least for a while until you think about
something else what about you know
family and friends are you worried about
them dying or leaving you behind
what does that the Cure say about death
how can you put that in perspective well
the one thing you die there's no you
anymore to be bothered about anything
so he made a little not worry about it
because as long as you're alive
it's no longer an issue and when you die
there's no you to be be concerned why
are some people worried about death
afraid of going to the bad place there's
a good lot of religions there's the good
place there's the bad place this is an
ancient Greeks have back to you - it
could be punished in the underworld or
you could go to the Elysian Fields if
you're a bad person and you're actually
willing you know admit that to yourself
you've done bad things maybe you're
afraid of going to hell it wouldn't it
be a nice thing that no there isn't any
how
Epicurus would say then you're not gonna
worry about that your life will be more
pleasant because you will not be
obsessed with fear he was also
interested in like natural phenomena you
know Greeks would see lightning and what
did they think that was and it's a
electrical current yeah it's not of Zeus
throwing Thunderbolts and why is this
angry and I started getting all these
trains of thought going and getting
afraid of things being afraid of
celestial phenomena as he says well if
you actually you know learn something
about them then you can say well that's
not actually Zeus that's just
electricity doing its thing yeah if you
learn something about statistics you
also realize unless you're like you know
wearing metal shoes or something like
that you're probably not going to get
hit by the lightning
so don't let it bother you
there's a lot of things like that where
you can have a better life by taking
away fear troubling mental pain you know
another one that you guys didn't put up
here that anything a lot of people are
afraid of embarrassment some people do a
lot of things to avoid embarrassment
because they're afraid of it what are
some of the things that we do just think
about our bodies for example what are
some of the things that we do with our
bodies to avoid the possibility of
embarrassment commercials play on this
yeah yeah I mean you should shower once
in a while you probably don't need a
shower you know everyday necessarily
unless you sweat a lot
you know or you're doing a lot of hard
work if you're showering five times a
day there's probably a lot of something
weird going on you know some people get
obsessive about these kinds of things if
you let it go a week no that's probably
you know grounds for for rethinking that
decision what goes in the shower yeah
yeah if you're not thin what else then
muscular toned those are important to be
right not that people make fun it's
interesting one of my my in-laws is an
actress and lives in LA and out here in
New York she's like you know a really
good thin figure out in LA she's not
skinny enough cuz I am you know there's
weird weird weird standards now she was
in Chicago she'd be even better you know
or if she was in Memphis she'd probably
be too skinny people might make fun of
her for that well well it's about our
physical how we dress don't wear the
wrong things people might look at you
weird when you'll feel embarrassed or
those god forbid they say something
about it don't you know that that jacket
is out of style everyone's wearing pin
spark jackets these days
give me yeah you know these are these
are the sort of things people do get
obsessed about especially like in middle
school high school hopefully less as we
get older you know so we have hygiene
appearance anything else people might
feel a sense of embarrassment about yeah
oh yeah we live in a weird time where
many people who have very strongly held
beliefs actually concealed them because
they don't want to be seen as judgmental
by other people because that would that
would embarrass them and so they don't
express themselves and they don't even
know that the person over there actually
thinks something similar to them it
could have a great conversation with
them because everybody keeps their mouth
shut
why don't students like to answer
questions in class yeah Barry spent
about what people could be about
strongly held beliefs but what else yeah
you could be wrong or it's just not good
enough for the teacher won't make fun of
you yeah yeah
we're afraid of we're afraid for the
content that we have of our beliefs were
afraid for other people not liking us or
afraid or peer at ignorant or even not
expressing ourselves well you know I
know the answer but I'm not quite sure
how to put it and I don't want to look
like a fool in front of all these people
who I don't know so I'm not gonna say
anything this is a very common student
experience when you life you want
liberated you know for you if you didn't
have any of those sort of fears here's
how I think here's things that you can
you can address those sorts of things
and I'm going to make this a very short
thing so you only get the talk about
friendship and love the desire think
about your desires you desire all sorts
of things
Epicure says when you're thinking about
your desires you can divide them up into
different sorts some of your desires are
natural and some of them are gonna be or
this distinction shows up in a number of
different epicurean texts in the letter
to OCS the principal doctrines the
Vatican sayings shows up over and over
and over again so it's something very
important for you what does it mean by
empty your name based on groundless
opinion now of the natural desires some
of them are necessary and some of them
are what they are natural let's think
about it clothing it yet now if you're
walking around MERIS campus you need to
wear some clothes if you don't do arrest
you right and you know you might have
run into all sorts of other problems too
you're down by the river wrong time here
you get it like mobbed by flies or
something like that do not wear elbows
now what kind of clothes do you need to
wear yeah it is a natural and necessary
thing to wear clothes in this kind of
environment if we were on a tropical
island would we need to wear clothes
maybe not we might need something you
know
to carry things around you
pockets are one of the best inventions
ever because I'm always shoving things
in my pockets I love the fact that you
know I've got these pockets
I didn't realize this but a lot of
women's fashion pockets don't actually
go anywhere you know
I end up carrying my my wives stuff
around I'll be like don't you have any
pockets yeah I can't put anything in the
holds at about why do you have a pocket
that well we start descending the order
that we start getting the things that
are less natural less necessary now
things that are natural and not
necessary so we need to wear the
particular clothes over wearing probably
it is natural for us to wear clothes
every culture just about you are the
ones living in tropical environments
have some sort of clothes usually what
about all the stuff that the fashion
industry tells us we might be wearing
let's based on what Epicurus calls
groundless opinion if you were to take
men's magazines and women's magazines
just like now that I pick these out of
the air because there's like millions
with Cosmo and Maxim or better yet if we
want to post a little - let's make it
Cosmo and GQ you don't need any that
stuff what would be that would be there
the female equivalent because Cosmo is
all sorts of you know feature articles
and sex tips and things like that
well what would be a women's magazine
that's just about fashion
what's that whoa okay so Vogue and GQ
you don't need any of the crap they have
in those magazines
there's people telling them if you want
to be fashionable but who said do you
want to be fashionable what good is it I
mean you know you can even be
fashionable this year and then have to
buy a totally new wardrobe next year
because it changes from time to time
what's fashionable in one place won't
turn out to be fashionable in other
places you know you go back into a
closet
somebody who's very fashion conscious
it's embarrassing to look at the stuff
that they used to wear and that's going
to keep on going forever that that's a
that's an industry that appeals to
people who Epicurus would say are
focusing on the sort of things that
aren't really going to make them happy
they're constantly chasing after
something new based on just grow its
opinion when if you really want to be
happy you want to stick with focusing on
your desires that are natural and
necessary so what would these include
well what do you have to do you have to
eat you have to sleep in a shelter you
probably need a job hopefully you have a
job that you actually enjoy you take
pleasure in it remove some of the pains
from your life of not having any money
or worrying about you know what's going
to happen to be in a month this is kind
of an interesting thing here
you know when it comes to eating for
example you need to eat something if you
don't you're gonna die and you know you
should eat something that tastes fairly
good and is nourishing do you need stuff
that's fancy that's got a lot of high
you know sugar fat salted it no you do
need some salt you can't go without salt
altogether where you'll die sugar does
serve some purpose is fat serve some
purposes you can't go on a no fat diet
either because that's bad for you as
well bad for your brain turns out but
you don't need a ton of it you certainly
don't need as much of it as we put in
our diet and then do you need to be
served it on special China oh you need
to make a deal how you know
environmentally conscious you are and
you know only have it served to you on
recycled paper plates that's equal
events according to somebody like that
[ __ ] you don't need it so if we prune
our desires to focus on those that are
natural and then the ones that are
necessary and we start trimming this
other stuff away from the light we're
going to be a lot happier for Epicurus
that meant pretty simple food hanging
out in this garden not pursuing
political office and I'll tell you
something else that it here's here's
where you might be turned off by
Epicurus literally turned off he
actually says that sex is not a
particularly good thing you want to
avoid it if you can trying to find this
this great quote the
dorita addressing a young man I
understand from you that your natural
disposition is too much inclined toward
sexual passion towards there's what we
call love or romance follow your
inclination as you will provided that
you neither violate the laws disturb
well established customs harm any of
your neighbors injure your own body
gonna waste your possessions doesn't
that sound like good advice you can you
can you know pursue your sexual desires
so long as you don't violate the laws
don't you know don't force yourself on
anybody what else do the laws cover only
consensual things just strictly you
don't disturb well-established customs
you don't harm any of your neighbors
that's a good thing right
injury your own body so you're not
future your kink is like let's come up
with something really weird
but the only way that you can actually
get off is by somebody hitting you with
a 2x4 that's not going to be good okay
that's not going to work for this
epicurean thing waste your possessions
that's an interesting one waste your
possessions as long as you're not making
your life depend on your sex life then
what does he say after that that you can
not be checked by one or more of these
provisions is impossible for a man never
gets any good from sexual passion and he
is fortunate if he does not receive high
Epicurus thinks that for the most part
sexual desire falls in the realm of not
necessary or empty a vein that it's
actually a bad thing for us the
Epicurean tries to live without getting
involved sexually so what do they spend
their time doing they're interested in
friendship and Epicurus thinks that
friendship is one of these necessary
desires why do we need friends do we
just need people to hang out with and
then we get lonely don't we yeah we
don't like the only but is that enough
to make a person really your friend the
fact that that you hang out with them
and you're not lonely
you're gonna replace that with something
else but you maybe get a cat then you
won't feel lonely or go online Facebook
then you're not lonely so what do we
need for my friends Epicurus is it the
basis of friendship originally is useful
friends are useful to us for helping to
ward off bad things the things that we
worry about the things that we're
concerned about taking away our pains
and friends are also useful for bringing
us pleasure that's why we become friends
with other people because they can make
us happier and so you know if somebody
doesn't make you happy don't be friends
with them now if you look at your list
of friends people that you call friends
Epicurus would say and you're going on
the list of some of the people there
just make you crazy they're not your
friends there is something else
according to advocates what else does he
tell us he says those who are overly
eager to make friends or not to be
approved but you shouldn't approve those
who avoid friendship risks should be run
Fritzing friendship goes from being just
a matter of usefulness and being
something that is one of the highest
goods it's worth taking risks for that
micariff things and this is a guy who's
all about risk management isn't he
when you read through this be prudent
don't engage in pleasures that are gonna
bring about more pains later but he's
saying you should risk things for
friends you should take some chances
not just any sort of chance don't become
friends with anybody that you wind up
meeting because they might turn out to
be a jerk
we're incompatible or a user but you
need to take some chances program
he also tells us here's another sort of
in the middle thing neither he who is
always seeking material aid from his
friends trying to make the friends
useful nor he who never consider such an
aid is a true friend one engages in
petty trade taking favorites of
gratitude you know there are some people
just use you you know you know the type
right but if you're friends with
somebody you should actually have some
level of relying on them and getting
something out of them Epicurus says
otherwise you're not really friends
you're just connections maybe he says
that the nobleman is chiefly concerned
with wisdom and friendship of these the
formers of mortal good and the latter
into mortal this takes us up to the
level of the gods
so friendship for Epicurus is really the
cement the pinnacle the thing that holds
everything together the keystone of the
happy life you can get rid of all your
fears you can enjoy some you know
positive pleasures within reason the
ones that are going to lead to being
hungover or waking up somewhere and
you're not sure you know where you are
or burning through all the all your
goods
but you need friends and that's what the
curious actually did he bought this
garden he said hey all my friends come
here and live with me and we're gonna be
sort of like a you know place we're just
hang out and talk philosophy and eat
some nice food and take a break don't
get bothered by politics don't get
bothered by family affairs don't get
bothered by romance or love
relationships the stuff that drives us
nuts let's not get drunk well let's have
you know a little wine mixed with water
from time to time we're not going to
banquets but we'll have some nice
healthy food
it sounds like certain people's wives
epicurean at the Cure's garden there's a
few other things that he says about
friendship that I think are particularly
interesting there's two remarks that he
makes he says the widest man feels no
more pain of being tortured himself than
when his friend is tortured and will die
for him if he betrays his friend his
whole life will be confounded by
distrust and completely upset now that's
not just any kind of friend is it when
we say I would die for you
we're just watching while I was just
calling the Beverly hillbilly because
they strike me as being kind of don't be
alien just in a different way the Jersey
housewives last night and it was
interesting to watch didn't watch it my
wife went to that show it's a guilty
pleasure and there was a couple when
they were talking about that they would
die for each other but they don't they
don't really like each other very much
most of the people on the show don't
really like each other just what people
enjoy watching is that the same thing
that Epicurus is talking about or is it
just me Revati something people tell
themselves to make themselves feel okay
about their take not just the wise man
he says feels no more pain when being
tortured himself than when his friend is
tortured he identified so much with this
trap that that friends pain is his pain
equally it's not a selfish you know
you're off over there and I can I can
live without anything and if you betrays
this friend his whole life will be
confounded by distrust and completely
upset there are certain friendships
Epicurus things that we can rise to the
level of where if we were to trade that
friendship our life would sort of lose
its meaning our our character would be
so shaken
you wouldn't know who we are that's an
interesting thing to keep in mind he
only makes that one remark like that but
that's something you could draw out of
it the other one that's that's at the
very high level
lower them are we all perfect people
whoever is raising no takers there's
some things about us that are quite as
nice I get impatient very easily and
don't listen to people and interrupt
even my best friend thinks I interrupt
you much that's a character flaw all
right if you want to be friends with me
you'd better become reconciled to being
interrupted every once in a while why
haven't I gotten rid of that character
flaw
I've actually toned it down
well Epicurus actually provides us with
an answer to that he says we place a
high value on our characters as if they
were our own possessions so each one of
you you have your character you have
your personality you have your quirks
you have the things that matter to your
values right and you're different from
each other you guys talk about
basketball right that's something
important to hear something you care
about
I'm not into basketball I'm into I'm
wearing the football some of you don't
care about that sort of stuff at all so
Revere into lacrosse we can keep on
going you know further and further and
further our life experiences are part of
our personality too so we place a high
value on our on our individuality on our
character now notice what he says after
that whether or not we are virtuous and
praised by other people so if we're if
we're virtuous if we're actually good
people we've developed good traits of
characters that's that's good
and if other people notice that and
praise us that's good too but we we like
ourselves who we are even if we don't
have that you know I like myself even
though I am I am a jerk who interrupts
way too often and I know I do and I even
know that I'm the kind of person who
probably is not going to change that and
I
interrupting people the rest of my life
but I still like the kind of person that
I am and I bet probably you do the to
not nuts person I am the person that you
are right now what does he go out and
say from that so too we must regard the
characters of those around us if they
are our friends so if we like ourselves
our personalities even if they're not
virtuous even if other people don't
praise us even if other people say hey
you're a jerk on occasion or quit
interrupting or develop a better
personality what about our friends if
I'm friends with you then at the curious
things if I'm really friend if I'm
actually gonna drive pleasure from your
company I have to come to see your
foibles you're nuttiness your
idiosyncrasies of your character is
something that I like something that
doesn't just drive you nuts that I
couldn't you know wish I could here away
from you but something that like you
says replace a high value on as if they
were our own possessions I should like
the fact that my friends are certain
types certain ways I should cherish them
what do you suggest
let's talk to do don't other people's
quirks drive us nuts don't we sometimes
feel like maybe I could fix them they're
there they're good but here's the areas
in which they could improve and we give
them a list
you're a jerk this way you're a jerk
this way here's what I want you to
change Epicure says we should leave that
sort of thing behind and he's not
spelling this out very well
but you know if you think about it
wanting somebody else who you want to be
friends with to change
so that they will be more compatible
with you and placing a great emotional
investment on your part in that is
probably a recipe for a lot more pain
than pleasure isn't it what's your
experience do people often make the sort
of changes that you would like them to
make in order to be your friends no no I
think that's probably going through
always given history that's part of
human nature that's what that's where
we'll leave off with these little
notions about friendship Epicurus has a
very interesting theory attraction
leaves out sexual desire parts right
you've got a lot to say on this time